こんにちは、はじめしゃちょーです
みなさん乗り物 何乗ってますか？
すごい抽象的で すいません
結構、世の中 乗り物多いと思うんですよ
まぁ一般的には
自動車、電車
とかいろいろあるんですけどもー
ま、それ以外にも乗り物って実は色々ありまして、
たとえばですけども、竹馬とか。スケボーとか。
キックボードとかね。
キックボードとか。
キックボードとかあるんですけども
そう キックボード！！！
キックボード乗ったことありますか！
なんか僕、小学生の時はもう
「自転車乗ってるやつらはだせぇ」
みたいな風潮があって、
「もう男は黙ってキックボード」
っていう時代があったんですよ。
知ってる人いるかわかんないですけども
こうやって乗って、地面をキックすると
前に進むっていうやつがあるんですけどもー
で、そのなんか、自転車とかスケボーとか、
キックボードに、総じて言えることはー
あの、全部ですねー、なんかこう、
力を入れなきゃいけない！
スケボーとかだと漕がなきゃいけないし、
自転車も…こうやって、なんか…
こういう動きが起きる。
キックボードも地面を蹴らなきゃいけないっつってー
動きがある乗り物って基本的になんかこう、
ですが。
ですが今日ですね、なんと
スポーツ用品店に行ったら、たまたまァ
「たぶんこれ一番 力が必要ないんじゃないか」
っていう乗り物を見つけてｓ…ました。
こちらです
すぺーす すけーたぁ
THE NEW WAY TO RIDE X560
“JUST PUMP & GO”って書いてあるんですけどもー
まぁ、やったらわかると思います！
一回開けてみましょう
ちなみに値段が1万3000円でちょっと高いっス
高い分マジですごいと思うんで！
久々にィ、外で撮ってるんでちょっと緊張してます
入ってるのはこんぐらいでした
めんどくせーけど
作っちゃうよ⭐︎
足つった！
[ﾍﾟﾘｯ]
多分ここら辺はなんとかなるんですけどー
これ、これな？
これがたぶん、敵になると思う。
えぇ？これ待って、これオレ終わったか？
あーでもこれ、なんとかできそうだな
あっ、いけた いけた
お？お？うぇ？
待ってもう もう もうだぞ多分
[ｶﾞﾀﾝ]
くそー、いろいろと……
なんか…す…すごい……
めんどくせえ…
これ取れたらたぶんもう終わりっスね
え、さてはこれ、やばいか？
えーやばい…
どう…すればいいんだ…
くそぉっ…(悔しみ)
あとここだけですたぶん。
誰か…誰か工具を…
えぇこれ待って、どう…えぇ…？
えぇー？
はい、鋭い石を見つけたんで
これでちょっと切り裂いてやろうと思います
やっぱ公園にいてもねー
なんとかなるんスよ結局。
これでなんとか、切り裂きますよ。
やっぱね、家のものに頼っててもダメなんスよ。
こういう、野外でも、オレはできるってのを見せたい
あるあるある
頑張れ石
頑張れ俺
ナレーションはじめ）そこには
ナレーションはじめ）公園に1人座り込む
ナレーションはじめ）26歳の
ナレーションはじめ）姿があったのです。
[ｷﾁｷﾁｷﾁｷﾁ]
お、お、お、お、お、
はぁっはぁっはぁっ
はぁーーーーっ
アアアア
ッチェーーッ
ゴミはちゃんと持ち帰りましょう。
ここまできたらもう余裕っしょ
多分あとはこのタイヤつけるだけです
こうやってぇ、ほいほいほい
おお できた×4
待ってくださいね みんな
もうちょっとっスよ！
俺の身長に合うぐらい高くしないきゃいけないんで
ここかなー
で、あとはハンドルをつけるだけです
えーもう完成っぽくね？
完成っぽいけどなんか不安なのはなんなんだろう
これもうやばいや
ここで1時間ぐらいこれ やってっかんね
ぅおっし……
多分できましたぁ
完成です。
こちらが近未来のぉー
乗り物です。
はっはっはっはっはー(快活)
はい、というわけで
見た目はただのキックボードだがー、
全然違うぞー
キックボードってのはこうやって乗ってー
蹴って、進むやつなんですよぉー
ですがこれは違います
蹴るんじゃなくてー
こう！こう！
わかり、ました？
伝わりますかねぇ
この、この、これですよ
こう。これこれ
この……これこれ！
わかります？このこれ！
これですよ
これこれこれこれ
だからもう蹴る必要もないんスよね〜
え、め↑っちゃ楽じゃない？これ
割と次世代な気がしますよ
はっはっはっは
いやすげー楽なんスよこれー
楽すぎて心配になるくらい
これで進みますよ
っていうのがあるんスよ
すごくないスかこれぇ
ちょっと どういうシステムかわかんないんですけど、
漕ぐとこうやって前に進むみたいな
押すとこうやって前に進むみたいな感じらしいです
はっはっは、◎△＄♪×￥！
こんなスピードが出ますよほら、はっはっは
はっは
あ、ああああああああああ！！！！
[ｶﾀｶﾀ]
見ててくれ俺の、華麗なドライビングテクニックを
男の子）はいっ
せっ(掛け声)
男の子）ちょっとかっこ悪かったですｗ
はい、というわけでみんな見てもらった通り
これマジで、楽だし早いんスよ！
で、この公園からー
あの、僕んちまでー
5キロぐらいあるんですけどもー
車だと16分かかるらしいです
で、徒歩だと1時間かかるらしいです
これぐらいの速さと楽さだったら
多分16分もかかんないぐらい。
もう多分、日が暮れる前までに
家まで着けると思うんでー
ちょっとどんぐらいで帰れるか
測ってみようと思います
多分 車より速いと思います！！！
なんなら自転車より楽です！！！
というわけで5キロを何分で帰れるか、
やってみましょう。
じゃ、ゴールで待っててくれ
いきます！
よーい、
どん！
じゃ…家で会おう
わあああっ(特に意味のない大声)
[ﾀﾝｯ   ﾊﾟﾀﾊﾟﾀﾊﾟﾀﾊﾟﾀ(足音)]
ゲホッゲホッ
ゲホッ
着きましたぁ〜……(苦しげ)
ハァッ…えっとタイムが
28分22秒
[通常ED]